you try to pay rent once for like within
your sock or something
what oh
oh yeah yeah i was just okay i'll tell
you a story
so like i was just thinking
it's 2 a.m in the morning yeah and i'm
like well i got i gotta pay rent to my
roommate real like yeah quick
so i had it the only way is to do it is
it cash 18 in new york right all right
yeah they're in new york my brooklyn
apartment yeah right right and the deli
is only like five minute walk so i'm
like okay i'll just go to the deli get
the 500
and then but i'm so stupid because in my
head i'm like well it's 2 a.m in the
morning
and
what if i get mugged right i should hide
it in a really good spot
and i hid it in my shoe
i hid in my shoe and while i was walking
back
the money flew out of my shoe
then i didn't know and i got back to my
apartment and i was like where's my
money so then i went outside like in the
dark like looking like this
and then like a bunch of like you know
people came up to me and he's like yeah
yo what you what are you looking for and
i'm like um have you guys seen any like
money like five hundred dollars around
like this
and they're like nah man and i knew they
were acting i knew i i think they picked
it up yeah yeah yeah oh man
dude i'm gonna see that's crazy what and
i was like okay i i know you guys have
it i didn't say that loudly
this is a gg i'm gonna call my dad and
be like yeah i lost to 500 sorry
i felt bad why did you shoot like you
didn't put it like deep into yours like
are you like letting it hang out yeah
you know
i i put it as deep as i don't know
you have a hole in your shoe maybe it's
just kind of like no i just maybe
physics or something i don't know man
physics
physics
i don't know man
all the mugging was just that good
dude i mucked myself
my favorite time in new york is like
going out like 2 a.m in the morning
because then you get like the crackheads
[Music]
why is that a good thing why is that a
good thing
i don't know it's kind of a it's a vibe
[Laughter]
because i'm a dude so yeah i'm
technically always safe but if you're
like a girl you're gonna it's real bad i
don't know man i've been to new york and
i never felt safe even like during the
day yeah no
actually being in japan i always feel
safe now yeah right this is crazy no
girls no stabbing yeah right i don't
know if i call that a vibe you know
gun noises
no you gotta learn how to how to talk to
them so what i do is when you go up and
talk to them no no if they approach you
all right okay okay
you got to be like homie to them so like
what i do is i like to say man so i'm
like so they go
this is a pro strategy okay okay they
approach you they're like give me two
dollars hey can i have two dogs and you
go no sorry man and then you gotta add
the man in there so so if i just say so
if i just say no so
no sorry they're gonna be they're gonna
be like no sorry yeah they're offended
you know
i'm not i'm not you know native to
america but i don't think that's gonna
like stop anything if someone wants no
it does you'll be surprised man
[Music]
i'm gonna punch you yeah yeah yeah
oh he's on my level
what dude the dude asking so like by
saying man what does that do like why
does that work
oh it's just it's just like it's just
like yeah just it's like word disarming
right right right right i better if this
is harriet
[Music]
like you're being friendly towards you
yeah yeah so if you just say no sorry
that's like kind of rude say no sorry
man or in like in that tone no sorry man
what if i say
i cannot provide you with the cash that
you require right now
that's another thing if you can make
them laugh they'll let you go
you know
i mean look like i believe
this one simple trick there's a part of
me that believes you but like not in
saying that i'm not gonna try it yeah
i mean i haven't been mugged yet so
yeah well
i mean i don't think i'll be mugged here
right i mean i i i already unlocked yeah
yeah yeah yeah unless it's an umbrella
in which case that's just like free
range oh yeah yeah yeah yeah someone
stole emily's umbrella yeah do you
be like that yeah people don't steal
here unless it's umbrellas yeah because
it's it's not your umbrella it's the
community on brother yeah
people are trying to make you join cults
really yeah it happens
it hasn't happened to me yet that's good
it will happen do i have to go to like
the countryside no you don't know don't
follow them
no you just have to be like sorry man
sorry right sorry
i don't want that man
i don't want to go pray yeah
i don't think it'll work here they don't
understand english that much
they're the cults too oh they do it yeah
speak they go forward yeah yeah my
tactic works yeah yeah just be like just
just say man yeah right
man i don't want to enjoy a caller
they'll ask you they'll ask you do you
want to pray you say no and then i'll
show you a picture of mount fuji yeah
and that's that should be your sign yeah
it's always mount for you always i
always question like what exactly do you
do with this cult though like they just
they they just like get money from you
yeah normally they make you kind of make
you do you live with them and then it's
usually i mean it's usually like it
starts off with like is this
brainwashing yeah it starts off with a
scam which then eventually leads on to
some like more yeah i don't say devious
licks but you know
that's a little uh you know serious
episode of golden time right there's
like a cult thing going on is that yeah
yeah japan and weirdly has a lot of
cults yeah yeah yeah they're really
really really like active yeah it's a
lot of really big ones as well yeah it's
because there's no like one organized
religion like a lot of countries so it's
kind of just like free-for-all basically
i'm guessing because of the aging
population as well it's very easy to use
i can't see it but i was like i was fine
and then conor like randomly like well i
was hanging out with him this dude just
randomly dropped yeah there's like a lot
of old people more old people than young
people i was like no there's not they're
not like the next week i've been walking
around i'm like
oh my god they're everywhere
everywhere
if you go to a supermarket it's probably
like 80 yeah elderly people it's
interesting i was like whoa i was i was
just like i saw a news article just the
other day i mean this is outdated by the
time being but like do you know what
percentage of the population is below 15
in japan wait wait would you say
what what what population what
percentage of the japanese population is
below 15 years old
what do you think
twenty percent ten percent
what the [ __ ] that's how that's how like
that's how many like old people there
are or older people there are less young
people less younger what happens when
everyone plays gotcha
i agree with that
the sex shop is all i needed to see
i did and i i saw some questionable the
full story one right yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah there's like
advertisement that's just like
yeah i pretend not to look yeah